hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear so every once in a while to get
ideas for these reviews these videos
I'll kind of go and browse through
various internet lists of kind of like
underrated underseen horror films
usually looking for an older movie that
I haven't seen before or that is
recommended right
so the other day I was actually doing
one of these browsing sessions and I
stumbled across a
1977 movie I think it's 1977 although
some dates say 1975 so I'm not real sure
um and this movie I had not only never
seen it but I had never even heard
anyone mention it at all ever like in my
entire life which that's a very unusual
thing to happen cuz even though I mean
there's a lot of movies like even from
the' 7s and ' 80s and stuff like that
that I haven't seen but I've usually at
least heard of them and it's like on my
list this one I had actually never heard
of now this movie was actually I believe
it was initially released like at a
pretty small like production company and
the title was initially false face but
it's better known today as scalpel now
this was directed by John Grismer uh I
guess is how you pronounce his last name
he's probably best known I think for
like the 1987 movie Blood Rage which uh
I actually have heard of
uh but that's the only movie that he had
done that I had heard of I had not heard
of this one so I was like well I'm going
to go check that out now I assumed just
from like a quick read through of the
synopsis that this was going to be
something along the lines of you know
like Eyes Without a Face the George
franu movie or uh Jess Franco The Awful
Dr orof like this is kind of a similar
plot um and I was partially right but
this movie scalpel actually has
something of like a Southern Gothic
angle to it which actually I really dug
now the subject matter is pretty lurid
um and I will say it kind of strains
credulity like at times uh and also the
main protagonist is an Unapologetic [__]
heel of like the highest order like
seriously he's the worst but honestly
like all of these things I when I say
them it sounds like I'm being negative
but I'm absolutely not because these
things were actually I think probably my
favorite things about the movie now I'm
actually not sure if the version that I
watched which somebody had uploaded to
YouTube in really nice quality I think
this is maybe on Prime video too I'm not
really sure you'd have to check um so
I'm not sure if this version had been
edited for Content I heard that it was
um cuz I did hear that the original film
like the theatrical cut like had more
nudity in it um this doesn't really have
any nudity other than like some side
boob I think was like the only thing
that you saw but this version that I saw
does have some gore in it nothing like
over the top it's mostly like Surgical
type Gore but some of it's like pretty
gnarly at least for the time now so I'm
not really sure what the deal is I'm not
sure if I saw like an edited cut or
whatever it didn't really seem like an
edited cut to me so but I just thought
I'd bring that up cuz I saw somebody
else mention it I believe this movie did
get a VHS release back in the day and it
was shown on
television but as far as I know it was
never even released to DVD so it's
remained like pretty obscure since it
came out um which is kind of a shame I'm
going to say like it's not really lost
Masterpiece or anything like that like
I'm not going crazy but it's pretty damn
good and it has like some really good um
acting performances especially the two
leads who I really thought did a great
job so Robert Lancing who I recognize
from Empire of the ants he was also in
some of the um episodes of like the
original Star Trek he plays this plastic
surgeon named Dr Philip Reynolds now
from the very beginning of the movie uh
you get a pretty clear sense that this
doctor is a little bit of a psychopath
maybe you know uh but to Robert
lansing's credit he plays this character
with just this real like a lot of
restraint and a lot of subtlety and you
almost can't help but like the guy even
though he's terrible you know what I
mean um he doesn't come across like as
this arrogant like cackling over the
toop villain he's actually like pretty
subtle and I think that works really
really well so not long into the movie
we find out that Philip's wife um has
died in a supposed accident which wasn't
an accident at all as you'll discover
and that he has a grown daughter like in
her 20s or something like that whose
name is Heather Heather is played by
Judith Chapman um she was on a [__] ton
of like soap operas back in the day
beautiful girl um I think she's related
to another actress that's kind of famous
too now so the daughter Heather she ran
away from home uh a year previously and
hasn't really contacted acted anybody in
the family since then now in a flashback
sequence we discover that the reason
that the poor girl took off is that her
dad you know the plastic surgeon caught
her and her boyfriend having sex and
then Dad drowned the boyfriend like in a
pond on the property and he made it look
like an accident again like he was like
oh the kid was drunk and he must have
just fallen in too bad so sad it was
that kind of thing um but Heather kind
of saw most of the [__] happen so she
knows what what so obviously she needed
some time alone to like process that
[__] you know what I mean oh hey my dad
murdered my boyfriend awesome so it was
just kind of like that so she just took
off you know so philli has this very
wealthy
father-in-law who always uh correctly as
it turns out blamed philli for uh his
daughter's death like for you know
Philip killing his wife accidentally
like I said now the father-in-law uh
croaks and in his will he leaves
absolutely bupkiss to Phillip or to his
own son uh whose name is Bradley so
Bradley is also Philip's brother-in-law
yeah now he does however leave a
whopping $5 million to his beloved
granddaughter Heather of course the only
problem about that is nobody knows where
the [__] Heather is um and she's been
gone for a year now fortuitously Phillip
and Bradley are driving around one night
kind of like commis commiserating and
like whining and stuff about getting
shafted in the old Coots will as they
both did when kind of opportunity jumps
up and smacks them in the face so
there's this stripper at a club who's
getting her face absolutely caved in by
this big ass bouncer for reasons which
are never explained but which it's not
really important um but this scene is
actually like pretty brutal like he's
basically just like bashing her face
like into a concrete wall like over and
over and her head is just like just a
massive bloody pulp like at the end so
it's pretty [__] up
so this young woman obviously you know
has a horrible head injury and she can't
really see and stuff like that she
staggers out into the street and happens
to collapse right in front of Philip's
car so Philip and Bradley like obviously
as you would they both get out of the
car and they rush to help her and they
take her to the nearest hospital which
happens to be the hospital where Philip
works and they start kind of like
getting her sorted out you know what I
mean now Phillip despite his shittery
does actually seem to want to help this
woman uh who who called Jane Doe like
for the rest of the
movie however when he realizes that she
doesn't really remember who she is and
she doesn't seem to have any family or
friends or anything that are looking for
her the doctor hits upon a slightly
unethical scheme let's call it that he
figures that since he had absolutely no
idea like what this woman looked like
like before she got all her [__] pushed
in he might as well reconstruct her face
to look exactly like the face of his
daughter Heather and while he's at it
also might as well train her to talk
like Heather and act like Heather um all
the better to claim that 5 million bucks
which was left to Heather by her dead
grandfather so obviously cuz her face
was pretty much this girl's face was
pretty much destroyed uh the recovery
process takes a while um and initially
Jane Doe here is pretty sked out by the
doctor and all of his sketchy uh mations
you know what I mean um however he is
eventually able to persuade Strongarm
her kind of um into splitting the $5
million with him even though he's like a
completely Lear and creep um but you
know she's she was working as a stripper
it's implied that she didn't have that
great of a life uh up to this point they
don't really go into it you know what I
mean and uh so she's like okay 5 million
bucks I guess I'll put up with this [__]
and do all of this sketchy [__] that
you're asking me to do so Philip takes
Jane back to his house so she can finish
healing up and then he also starts
instructing her on how to be Heather
like he plays her recordings of
Heather's voice like he makes Jane copy
samples of her handwriting and he does
like all these like quizzes about like
all of the um relatives like cuz like
you know all of these people you're
going to have to meet them and [__] like
that and it's this huge like very
Southern very old old money type of
family like this was shot and is set in
Georgia um so it's very old South you
know what I mean everyone's like y'all
come back now you're here and you
drinking mint jeps and all that kind of
[__] so it's that kind of stuff so
there's like a 40 bajillion relatives
and she has to remember all of them and
details about them and stuff like that
because these are all people obviously
that have known Heather all their lives
so Jane is really going to have to be
like top of her game if she's going to
fool them you know now it turns out that
Jane actually does a quite commendable
job going to say of imitating Heather
and seems to be able to pass for you
know Philip's missing daughter obviously
her only big downfall and they didn't
really have time to address this
obviously is that the real Heather is
essentially like a musical prodigy she
was like a piano virtuoso and Jane can
obviously not play the piano all she can
play is chapsticks now this um almost
gets her into trouble when because
there's this big family party which is
kind of celebrating her comeback you
know like with all the relatives and
friends and everything there and Bradley
you know the um Philip's brother-in-law
he like insists on her playing something
it's like you know and she wasn't
prepared for it obviously now Philip is
able to kind of get her out of this by
saying it's like oh while she was away
she had like this bad shock or this bad
trauma and she lost her ability to play
the piano but you know the doctor says
it'll be back and it'll be fine but like
you know don't crowd her right now like
let her get over it or whatever so that
kind of works but Bradley um is
obviously kind of suspicious about the
situation as you probably would be now
in spite of all these setbacks though um
Philip and Jane are able to successfully
convince the you know the family lawyers
to hand The Inheritance over to Jane the
whole $5 million and just as they
planned um she immediately like makes a
gift of half the money to Phillip like
she says oh I always thought that
granddaddy was so mean to him and it's
just like so I want to give half my
money to my daddy and all that kind of
stuff so then the the pair of them
return back to Philip's you know
palacial Mansion which is implied was
actually the grandfather's house
initially so I guess like when Philip
married the wife that he killed like
they moved into the house but it's like
a really nice like it's a mansion
essentially like a big um you know like
a big southern plantation house so they
go back there and they're like wooho we
got all the money they go let's go do
something fun they go to Six Flags and
ride roller coasters or whatever and oh
yeah they also start [__] um which ew
I mean okay so they're not related
obviously but it's still pretty weird
like for a middle-age to older dude to
start having sex with a woman who's not
only half his age but who's also like
the exact clone of his daughter like not
only looks exactly like her but also
talks like her and acts like her and
everything like that I mean that's weird
right I mean I think that's weird like
there's just so much to unpack there
like from a psychological standpoint um
and believe me the movie does get ickier
uh as as time goes on I mean this is a
Southern Gothic and this kind of like
par for the course course but yeah just
that this isn't as gross as it gets is
what I'm going to say okay so remember
how I said that Bradley was getting uh
suspicious about this Heather not really
being who she's uh appearing to be um
which yeah he's right about that well he
turns up unannounced at Philip's house
one night when neither of them are home
and he just like lets himself in like
you do uh sits in the Parlor for them
and he's just like drinking their booze
and you know getting drunker and getting
angrier and [__] like that because
recall that not only because here was
the thing not only did he think it was
weird that you know Heather can't play
the piano anymore like he thought that
was a little bit strange but you also
have to remember that that Bradley was
with Phillip when they found the
stripper with the smashed up face so
Bradley is not stupid and he is able to
like kind of put two and two together
and be like oh this is probably an
imposter like he fixed her face to look
like daughter's face you know what I
mean he figured it out now you might
think that Philip and Jane are going to
have to kill Bradley to keep him from
ratting on them right but it turns out
that they don't exactly need to Bradley
has like a heart condition um he takes
medication for it and he ends up at this
particular night like getting so drunk
and so worked up about the whole
situation that his heart starts to give
out and he collapses so pretty much all
Philip does is he doesn't kill him
directly but he kind of holds his
medication like out of his reach so he
can't get it and then so he just like
stands there and coldly like watches him
pass away like on the floor you know
what I mean so again this appears to be
just simply a tragic natural death you
know what I mean and so now the incest
twins are supposedly in the clear again
right but then a new wrinkle appears in
the form of the real Heather who
actually shows up at Bradley's funeral
but she kind of keeps on the down low
she kind of like stays behind a
gravestone and just like watches
everything from afar so then she goes
back to Philip's house when no one's
home lets herself in which you know a
lot of people seem to be doing that at
this house and she cooks him this big
dinner like to surprise him now Phillip
is actually over [__] joyed to see
his daughter at long last cuz he's
really Mis and Heather acts like it's
not bizarre in the least that her father
father is [__] a woman who looks
exactly like her and is like the same
age as her and stuff and I'm going to
say that um just like from the
interactions between the father and the
real daughter it's pretty obvious that
Phillip had the hots for his daughter
like all along which I guess goes a long
way toward explaining like why he killed
her boyfriend the year before because I
guess he was jealous he didn't want
another man having her or whatever now
Heather uh says she was unaware that her
grandfather had died and that her
grandfather had left her all that money
so Philip actually just lies to her and
says oh man that old bastard he just
left all the money to the local College
nobody in the family got a red
scent um now also while that's going on
Jane is also starting to perceive that
she's kind of becoming a third wheel now
that Heather's back and she starts to
get um concerned that Heather is going
to interfere with this whole scheme that
her and Philip have going on because
Heather is like pretty smart and she's
like she's going to figure out like what
we're up to you know what I mean now
mindful of Jane's
anxiety Phillip actually reassures her
oh I've hired a Hitman to have Heather
killed and he acts like allity he's like
this is my baby I can't believe I'm
going to do this but you know we have to
do this because she's going to find out
about us bloody blah and there's
actually like this great sequence where
the supposed Hitman who's supposedly
masquera as a plumber turns up at the
house like while Heather is there alone
and then it kind of goes back and forth
between these two scenarios so like
meanwhile the other scenario is that
Philip and Jane are out spending the day
on the lake and while and during those
scenes there's also a couple of kind of
suspenseful fake outs when you think
that philli has actually drowned Jane
like he did to his wife and like he did
to Heather's boyfriend right but no
she's fine and she actually seems happy
knowing that while she's out like
happily doing the backstroke in her
little skimpy red bikini Heather is
being put out of the way permanently
back at the house by the supposed
plumber not so fast though it turns out
that the plumber was an actual plumber
and not a hitman at all and it also
turns out that Phillip actually hired a
local cop to pull him and Jane over like
on their way back back from the lake
then he pretends that he doesn't know
Jane she's just some hitchhiker he
picked up and then the cop tries to Cuff
her and she runs off and then the cop
starts chasing her and it becomes pretty
obvious at this point that Philip has
actually paid a Hitman but it's this guy
it's this cop um and he's paid the
Hitman to kill Jane and not his daughter
which you know Jane probably should have
seen that coming not going to lie so we
don't actually see what happens to Jane
yet but then Phillip goes back to the
house and tells Heather that Jane
drowned accidentally which you know
seems to be a running theme with him I
guess and now it's just the two of
them he then tries to rape his own
daughter which again [__] ew it's
like I told you it was going to get
ickier so you know what I'm saying
however he has stopped from doing so
when Jane pops up behind him and
clobbers him with a cast iron skillet
now I'm not absolutely sure this was
slightly
unclear but I thought that the movie
implied here that Jane and Heather had
switched places for this whole scenario
I mean I thought there were a couple of
lines like implying that which would
mean that it was Heather at the lake
with her dad the whole time like they
got chased by the cop and Jane who
almost got raped not that it makes the
[__] any better because Philip still
tried to jump on her like thinking it
was his daughter but I'm just saying I
thought the implication was that they
had switched places earlier like and
like offscreen so it would be more
suspenseful you know what I'm saying but
I'm not entirely sure if that's the case
so now comes the exposition so while
Heather was away that whole year she was
actually in a
sanitarium um you know cuz she went
there because she was freaked out
because she's like oh my God my dad
killed my boyfriend that was like which
you know you can't blame her right now
the only person in the family who knew
that she was there was her grandfather
so of course she knew that he had died
and she also knew that he had left her
all his money now Heather's therapist
while she was at the sanitarium tried to
convince her to report her father to the
police for murdering her boyfriend which
obviously but she evidently wanted to
get revenge on him like in her own way
she's playing the long game is what I'm
saying so when she came back home and
got to the whole Jane situation she
figured she could use that to her
Advantage I guess so while Jane and
Heather seemed to hate each other at
first because there's like a lot of
jealousy and stuff going on there it
seems that offscreen and kind of
subtly um they were kind of becoming
allies and I guess at some point they
decided to work together to like [__]
philli over so after Philip wakes up
from getting his [__] head bashed in
Heather and her therapist are sitting
there looking at him and they very
calmly at this was great they very
calmly tell Phillip that Jane was a
complete figma of his imagination that
it was just this sick fantasy that he
had constructed out of his desire to
bang his own daughter essentially the
more they tell Phillip this like and
they're very serious and they're just
like straight-faced and everything like
that and they're just like yeah there's
nobody there Daddy it's like there's no
such person and blah blah blah and it
was like it was so [__] funny so the
more they do that like the more off the
rails he goes right I mean he wasn't the
most sane person to start with so it's
not like he had a long distance to go
but I'm just saying and at last he's
just reduced to this completely
gibbering mess who just keeps seeing
hallucinations of all the people he
killed either directly or indirectly
like including his wife the boyfriend
and Bradley you know so at this point uh
Philip gets unceremoniously like you
know carded off to the asylum in a
straight jacket and then in the end Jane
and Heather which I thought it was kind
of cool split the 5 million bucks um you
know Heather's actually like pretty cool
she like you know she's got enough money
so she gives Jane the other 2 and2
million um and Heather stays behind at
the big palacial mansion and they both
end up happy and wealthy so all is well
that ends well now as I mentioned I
don't know I don't think I'd go so far
to say it's like an Undiscovered classic
or anything like that but it is a pretty
fun a pretty riveting and very like I
must say a very alluringly trashy like
Southern Gothic horror Thriller um yeah
I I kind of like the Trashy element to
it I mean Robert Lancing is just Stellar
in this as this kind of
sociopathic main character he's just
Charming enough that you can't stop
watching him but he's also a gross
pervert and he's like shady as hell but
like you still can't I don't know if I'd
go so far to say you like him but you
can't stop watching him you know what I
mean um Judith Judith Chapman who plays
um Jane and Heather I mean she's
Sensational um you know she has dual
roles she plays the characters really
similarly obviously because you know one
is supposed to be impersonating the
other one so they have to act likee but
she gives each character like real
subtle little tells so you can always
determine like which one is which you
know now as I mentioned earlier too it's
like I think some of the plot twists
stretched believability a bit like
especially toward the end with the whole
Switcheroo thing and this whole plot
that they were cooking up like behind
the scenes um but I'm going to say I
didn't find it to be like too egregious
or two out there and really kind of
exagger exaggerated narratives like this
are you know pretty standard for the
Gothic genre anyway so it's not like it
was anything like way out of bounds or
anything so I'm going to say I mean if
you're looking for kind of just like a
fairly
obscure 7s horror film with kind of like
some old South flare to it and uh some
pretty gross [__] incesty family
Dynamics so like I said kind of Southern
Gothic um this you know you might want
to give this one a wh like I said I
think it might be on Amazon Prime but
you'd have to check and see but some
somebody has uploaded a really Nic
looking copy of it to YouTube uh which
is where I watched it as I said I'm not
really sure if it was edited from the
theatrical version because this movie is
really obscure like I said it did get a
VHS release but as far as I know it was
never released on DVD or any other media
so it kind of like fell between the
cracks and like I said that's kind of a
shame cuz this is actually like a pretty
decent 1970s horror movie and I quite
enjoyed it that will do it for this
flickers of fear remember to like share
subscribe and comment and I will see you
guys again on the next one
bye